bonjour à tous aujourd'hui danse qui mag
on va parler économie attendez attendez
attendez partez partez pas n'ayez pas
peur
plus précisément je vais tenter de vous
y faire voir un peu plus clair dans le
budget 2016 de saint quentin en yvelines
trois points sont à retenir pour bien
comprendre ce qui va suivre
premier point le budget voté le 24 mars
dernier par le conseil communautaire est
un budget de transition puisque de
nouvelles communes viennent de rejoindre
saint quentin en yvelines et que de
nombreux détails restent encore à
définir
deuxième point vous l'entendez partout
dans les médias la dotation de l'état
aux collectivités locales est en baisse
drastique mais c'est le troisième point
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'à saint
quentin en yvelines
la part du budget dédié aux
investissements est maintenu
ceci étant dit je vous propose d'étudier
un peu plus en détail l'impact de ce
nouveau budget sur votre quotidien c'est
parti
et
pour nous puissions commencer ce conseil
d'agglomération est ce qu'on peut faire
l'appel
le 24 mars dernier les élus du conseil
communautaire voter le budget 2016 de
saint quentin en yvelines
bon ce n'est pas un scoop en matière de
budget on le sait depuis quelques années
l'état ferme les robinets
ainsi saint quentin en yvelines perd
cette année 5 millions d'euros une
baisse importante qui touche également
les partenaires de l'agglomération comme
le département ou la région qui vont
devoir diminuer leur participation à
certains projets portés avec saint
quentin en yvelines
mais les élus se disent confiants et
prêts à faire face au désengagement de
l'état
il ya des décisions aussi fortes qui ont
été prises il ya des économies à faire
donc
elle porte sur l'ensemble des secteurs
de l'agglomération sur l'ensemble des
services de l'agglomération
donc c'est skoda d'eau demandé et je
crois que chacun a fait l'effort déjà la
première chose nous avons fait un budget
devant souhaité avoir un budget sans
augmentation fiscale c'est-à-dire les
ménages et entreprises de repas à payer
le désengagement de l'état
donc nous le faisons sur les réductions
et ces réductions se font bien sûr sur
l'ensemble des services donc aujourd'hui
nous souhaitons que nos services
puissent se faire là même la même chose
mais avec moins de possibilités
budgétaires
nous essayons de mutualiser au maximum
et aujourd'hui des actions que nous
devons mener
alors bien sûr ça se fait en interne
dans nos services mais aussi avec les
services des villes est aujourd'hui
l'effort doit se poursuivre encore et
notamment avec les communes entrante
dans le nouveau périmètre de
l'agglomération de saint quentin
la deuxième chose aussi c'est que il
faut quand même que nous maintenions
d'investissement fort parce que le
territoire est en développement donc on
fait des efforts dans le fonctionnement
en réduction par contre nous essayons
d'avoir toujours un budget
d'investissements conséquents et cette
année nous aurons gore 33 millions
d'investissements
point également important à souligner la
baisse de la dette demeure une priorité
sur saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes sur cette partie là
particulièrement bien noté au niveau des
agences de notation qui salue notre
gestion de la dette
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure
l'investissement est maintenue cette
année sur saint quentin en yvelines on
peut même dire qu'il augmente légèrement
puisqu'il passe de 29 millions d'euros
l'an dernier à 33 millions d'euros cette
année
alors comment cet argent va t'il être
dépensés je vous propose de le découvrir
à travers quelques exemples concrets
une intercommunalité qui vit c'est une
intercommunalité en mouvement pour
faciliter les déplacements de chacun sur
le territoire saint quentin en yvelines
finances la réfection et l'entretien des
voiries d'intérêt communautaire chaussée
piste cyclable arrêts de bus ou encore
éclairage public
c'est la part la plus importante du
budget 2016 en tout ce sont 10 millions
six cent mille euros qui seront engagées
par exemple pour la rénovation de la
voirie et de divers réseaux dans la zone
d'activités de la joue à la verrière la
réfection de la dalle 17 mar à elancourt
ou bien encore les travaux des pistes
cyclables à voisins le bretonneux avenue
de port royal et du plan de l'église
ainsi que rue des berges et des mouettes
toujours côté transports 780 mille euros
sont consacrés à l'entretien et la
gestion du pôle multimodal de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'une des vitrines du dynamisme saint
quentinois qui a bénéficié récemment
d'importants travaux de réhabilitation
et d'embellissement la gare accueille
quotidiennement quelques 70 mille
voyageurs un million cent mille euros
sont destinés au développement
économique qui comprend notamment le
futur pôle de l'innovation et de
l'entrepreneuriat à guyancourt
ce bâtiment ouvrira ses portes d'ici la
fin de l'année aux porteurs de projets
innovants et aux dirigeants de sociétés
en quête d'outils pour faciliter leur
développement
il est géré par la communauté
d'agglomération son conseil
d'administration comprend plusieurs
chefs d'entreprise il s'agit d'accroître
encore les conditions de réussite de nos
entrepreneurs c'est pour ça que on
ajoute cet incubateur de haute qualité
avec bien entendu un ensemble de
stimulation positif pour leur simplifier
la vie qu'y perdre un minimum de temps
pour trouver de l'argent pour trouver un
partenaire managériale pour trouver des
clients on a même des systèmes
d'accélération de prospects rendez vous
voyez on est on les fait rentrer
également dans des réseaux
d'entrepreneurs aériennes telles que des
changes et bien sûr avec vos homologues
ils ont une salle de vue de
visioconférence de haute qualité aulas
pour éviter de dépenser de l'argent dans
un billet d'avion pour la new york
bien sûr il ya tout un écosystème de
moyens mais de personnel par exemple
vous avez la maison de l'entreprise
tous les services de la maison
entreprises qui sont dedans donc qu'ils
sont bien sûr formé à répondre à toutes
les premières questions que se posent un
jeune créateur d'entreprise
il y à là il ya tous les segments a
priori qui sont qui sont présents de
qualité dans des conditions vraiment
comme très optimisé on veut que
saint-quentin soit un modèle des
meilleures pratiques pour surfer réussir
nos chefs d'entreprise
actuellement cet espace est en travaux
il devrait ouvrir ses portes fin 2016
et puisqu'on en est aux travaux
n'oublions pas l'aménagement de l'espace
communautaire
un poste important dans le budget 5
millions cinq cent mille euros avec
notamment le projet de la zac de
l'aérostat attrape à terme être comptera
850 nouveaux logements construits par
des promoteurs privés
la communauté d'agglomération assure
quant à elle le réaménagement urbain du
quartier création de chaussée arrêt de
bus pistes cyclables et stationnement
travaux d'assainissement ou encore pose
d'éclairage de réseaux de gaz
d'électricité et d'eau potable
saint quentin en yvelines se charge
également de l'aménagement et de la
gestion des espaces verts 3 millions 500
mille euros consacrés aux plantations
réhabilitation des berges ou bien encore
réparation des fontaines cette partie du
budget sert par exemple au financement
de projets comme la liaison douce entre
pie salou et l'île de loisirs attrape le
remplacement du platelage et de la
structure en bois qui ceinture le lac de
villa roy ainsi que l'aménagement de la
grande île à voisins le bretonneux
gestion des services d'intérêt collectif
1 million 800 mille euros derrière cet
intitulé un peu technique se cache entre
autres l'entretien des réseaux notamment
celui de l'eau cette année plusieurs
chantiers seront menés sur le réseau des
eaux pluviales pour prévenir les risques
d'inondation et moderniser les
installations existantes par exemple à
la verrière des travaux d'enfouissement
seront réalisés rue des fleurs et rue
des vieux prés
la culture n'est pas en reste à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 5 millions
d'euros sont dédiés à la construction et
la gestion des équipements culturels
c'est le deuxième poste de dépense de
l'agglomération il comprend plusieurs
interventions dans les médiathèques de
voisins-le-bretonneux trappe guyancourt
elancourt
mais le plus gros chantier est
incontestablement celui de la
réhabilitation de la médiathèque du
canal du musée de la ville et du théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à montigny
le bretonneux
par ailleurs une enveloppe de 750 mille
euros pour le développement des
spectacles dans les 12 communes a été
débloqué cette année l'année dernière
quand nous avons élaboré notre premier
budget réel de l'année 2015
nous avions fait effectivement des
économies très très forte dans le
secteur de la culture
donc il y a toujours depuis ya toujours
eu depuis quelques années un
accompagnement pour les spectacles
vivants pour les communes historique et
donc cette enveloppe nous nous y avions
bien sûr toucher nous l'avons réduit de
manière assez significative
nous avons travaillé avec l'ensemble des
maires c'est à dire avec les 12 maires
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint quentin et nous avons convenu
qu'il fallait laisser une enveloppe pour
permettre là aussi l'accès à la culture
pour tous et permettent de pouvoir
accompagner les communes dans cette
politique
aujourd'hui le travail consiste tout
simplement à définir les critères pour
la répartition de cette enveloppe
je rappelle que des critères existait
auparavant et je pense le il n'était pas
satisfaisant pour l'ensemble des
communes pour nous le souhaitons que
chacun puisse participer à l'élaboration
de ces critères afin que cette politique
soit menée d'un commun accord
la plus grande nouveauté cette année
c'est évidemment le périmètre de
l'agglomération
ce qu'il faut donc retenir c'est que le
budget voté le 24 mars ce dernier est un
budget de transition
c'est un budget de transition et on va
non pas l'oublier très très vite mais on
va se dire qu'il va falloir ouvert les
chantiers très rapidement dans les
prochaines semaines pour préparer
justement l'enjeu majeur c'est le budget
2010 est qui sera apte à mon sens
sûrement différent du budget 2016 et
avec peut-être quelques ruptures nous le
verrons je ne je ne préjuge de rien
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
et bien tout simplement que 2016 est une
année charnière pour l'instant le budget
et celui des sept communes historique
consolidé par celui des cinq communes en
évidemment les services aux habitants ne
sont pas impactés dans les prochains
mois on devrait en savoir plus sur
l'avenir budgétaire de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ce
notamment grâce au cl c'était ok ok
j'explique le clc t il s'agit de la
commission locale d'évaluation des
charges transférées n'en sait toujours
pas claires et bien écoutez stéphane
denis rambaud va vous expliquer en quoi
elle consiste exactement ce qu'ils ont
fait est très très simple en entrant en
fusionnant avec la caisse qui les
communes entrantes ont transféré une
partie de leurs fiscalités
essentiellement la fiscalité
professionnelle
par la suite nous devons évaluer les
charges également que les différentes
communes ont transféré à cette
intercommunalité
un exemple simple
villepreux avait des charges relatives à
la piscine intercommunale que la ville
gère avec les villes de des classes ou
loi et la ville de pelé de plaisir on a
transféré des charges donc l'objectif
c'est simplement de faire le solde entre
la fiscalité que vous avez transférer
nos c'est une recette pour
l'intercommunalité les charges que vous
allez transférées sont une dépense et on
regarde au final qu'il reste à reverser
pour la commune
la commission locale d'évaluation des
charges transférées se réunit une fois
par mois
elle devrait rendre sa copie avant fin
2016 contribuant ainsi à l'élaboration
du saint quentin en yvelines de demain
dans un canton d'evelyne bien sûr ce
budget est quand même un budget
ambitieux même si à des réductions
notamment au niveau du fonctionnement
comme je vous l ai dit non maintenant un
investissement très fort et surtout nous
essayons de penser à la communauté
d'agglomération de demain la conversion
de demain c'est bien sûr de priorité au
développement économique très très
important deuxièmement c'est aussi
permettre l'épanouissement de nos jeunes
et notamment de nos étudiants avec un
campus universitaire et qui se renforce
et bien sûr qu'il fera le lien avec
paris saclay puis c'est tout le travail
que nous faisons dans le développement
nous avons aujourd'hui dedans peu
promoteurs qui travaillent sont un
territoire et qui sont toujours aussi
intéressés je reviens
ebeam à cannes je peux vous dire que le
territoire de saint quentin est toujours
aussi attractif qu'avant et même je vais
dire plus puisque d'autres territoires
sont en concurrence avec nous sauf que
nous c'est une réalité alors que dans
certains territoires
ils vendront corps des espoirs voilà
j'espère que désormais vous cerner un
peu mieux le budget de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ski mag c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui mais on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro
d'ici là portez vous bien ciao bye